[Music]
Harlen started out with a rusty
smith-corona and built himself into one
of the best-selling mystery writers of
all time 30 languages over 80 million
copies sold you guys fans I mean I don't
do much fiction reading myself big fan
mr. bunk is a private investigator of
great for now I read a tweet about a New
Yorker article about you you're famous
the none of his demise the family had
gathered to celebrate your father's 85th
birthday and your son ransom video 10 as
well yes but he left early
I think Glenda was upset Walt would get
a little Irish courage and he'd get into
it with Harlan what Richard said what
are you baiting me detective attempting
to be thorough so we can figure out the
manner of death you mean if someone
killed him do you think one of us one of
his family
mr. Blanc I just buried my father who
committed suicide why are you here
I suspect foul play
I have eliminated no Sussman Harlan was
cleaning house everyone in the family
has possible motive was halt and
planning on cutting off Joey did he play
the file Walter near the Richard having
an affair that's some heavy-duty
conjecture funny ransom you skipped the
funeral but you're early for the will
reading up your ass very nice family is
truly desperate when people get
desperate the nerves come out this is a
twisted waiver and we are not finished
untangling it not yet keep waiting for
the big reveal
all of them lied to me there is long
feel cheap on behind and all
you know something spill it oh my god
tell me what happened to my grandfather
I think you have something you want to
tell me
am i dead you're in a coma
you mean this is only dreaming memories
everywhere Nicole knuckles - the same
common space here in a coma some people
develop unique abilities but to discover
those abilities a person need a portion
needs to be put in danger now maybe
we'll see what your ability will be
the man from the balcony is he the
leader he taught us how to survive we're
here for a reason
everyone who's here didn't make it in
reality
they didn't have a future there
you haven't figured out nothing at
I am the one in charge here
if this world is made of memories how
did they get here there's an island for
your Reapers somewhere in the coma
we're always looking for people who can
help us get there
is this my life now I remember that I
couldn't be together with who I wanted
to be
here it's possible
our world would never appreciate
something unusual even if it's a hundred
times better
what do you mean reality for after that
we need to wake up
you can't wake up do you understand
your body is their income you are here
there's nothing you can do about it
life in coma is as real as it gets I
said hold it
[Music]
this will not be a war of heroes
which is all to see this is going to be
fun the world burns you have no idea of
what men are capable of
we must do something I know you want to
fight
but there are other ways of doing your
duty you're going to need a suit come on
we are the first independent
intelligence agency preserving peace and
protecting life well
while governments wait for orders our
people take action
even minds and blood destruction now
it's done too short a lot
Deb construction
my dear
[Music]
our enemies think we are gentlemen
but reputation there's what people think
of you
character is what you are
and ready Jeff
[Music]
but ready we shall see
this is called a parachute it means that
one can jump out of a plane safely
[Applause]
it's time to introduce myself
[Music]
just three ounces of pressure to the
vagus nerve and then look at your boy
sleepy night night Blanche sterling the
legendary spy who's always dressed to
impress
Walter Beckett graduated MIT at 15 and
works in the tech innovations lab there
are so many gadgets I want to test in
the field for example the inflatable
hook kind of a personal protection
device I've been developing this is a
vile waste of taxpayer dollars this is
your next objective none of our agents
can get close to him I have something
that can help it's called biodynamic
concealment imagine if I can make you
disappear hey Lance look at me look at
you I can see my butt and your face at
the same time that is so cool
being a pigeon could make you an even
better spy pigeons are everywhere nobody
notices them as you can see in slow
motion
that was tight did anyone else see a
pigeon and [ __ ] can flight up to 92
miles per hour don't you throw me
officers he'll figure it out
all right camera starting it's about to
get messy
time to go sleepy night
I miss my hands I gotta stay you're
squeezing - OH
what happens in a submarine stays in a
submarine
[Music]
I guess
[Music]
that's the way
these things go
so my baby
[Music]
I found grace
[Music]
so my
so so
[Applause]
in
cage and wait
[Music]
[Music]
so
you ready
[Applause]
[Music]
how long have known each other chin I
ever break a promise to you I will put
you in the driver's seat
Philemon just shut your mouth and let me
do my thing
all right morning Shelby morning Molly
up yours now go to help
that's it folks Ferrari wins - 24 hours
of LaVon for the fifth consecutive year
mr. Ford Ferrari has a message for you
sir what did they say she said for it
makes ugly little cars and ugly
factories and God you fat sir we're
gonna bury Ferrari at LeMond so the
great Hal Shelby is gonna build a car to
beat Ferrari with a forward correct and
how long did you tell them you needed
two or three hundred years 90 days who
hates guys like us because we're
different we heard he's difficult Tim no
no Ken's a puppy dog
[Music]
so there's a problem the computer will
find out get some scotch tape and a ball
of wool what are they doing making your
car faster
and miles it's not a fort man we're on
the verge of something and now you tell
me that I can't have the best man in the
world behind the wheel give me one
reason why I don't fire everyone
starting with you well sir the lighter
work faster and that doesn't work we're
nastier go ahead girl go to war I risk I
thought the whole point was to win the
top trace
if this were a beauty pageant
we just lost looks aren't everything
far away as north as we can go once
stood an enchanted forest you see an
enchanted forest yes it was a magical
place but something went wrong since
then no one can get in or out paddock
what would I do without you you'll
always have me how's the ELSA seemed
weird to you she seems like Elsa there's
this voice voice what does that mean
the kingdom is not safe find who is
calling to you they may have found sense
I'm going with you
Anna no excuse me I climb to the North
Mountain survived a frozen heart and
saved you from my ex-boyfriend so you
know I'm coming
it's normally
where are we how'd it get in the forest
the mist parted for impossible where did
you learn magic
[Music]
you can't just follow me into fire and
don't run into fire
[Music]
magic is very alluring without you she
may lose herself
protect arendelle at all cost
[Music]
I believe in you Elsa
or anything
[Music]
quick question is the whole putting up
some mortal danger gonna be a regular
thing Frank Sheeran cuz I know right
yeah you said right under the contract
management can only fire a driver on
very specific charges so you have a show
up late give any moving violations no do
you drink on the job
no never hit anybody on a job yeah I
don't think so
alright then we don't have nothing to
worry about want you to be my cousin
Russell Bufalino oh yeah hey nice to
meet you he was like the army
you followed orders you did the right
thing
you got rewarded
the friend of ours is having new trouble
friend at the top back then there was
nobody in this country who didn't know
who Jimmy Hoffa was always charged a guy
with a gun with a knife you run away
so you're charged with a gun with a
knife you run now your friend would you
like to be part of history yes I would
big business and the government working
together trying to pull us apart
something's got to be done what else he
say now's not the time to not say we're
going at war with these people for
things have gotten an e with our friends
you gotta sit down everybody says so
it's what it is one of this I knew
things they don't know why
it's gonna happen either way he's going
[Music]
you know I don't okay well you did it or
not that makes no difference to me
yeah I'm here to defend you right right
do you wanna know if I did that
[Music]
[Music]
did you hear that
someone out there
Cal Benjy
something's not right about this I think
we should head back to the road okay
Travis who are you what no no my boy
he's lost in here too so you feel you
can find things but it's easier once
they're dead
[Music]
how long have we been here sure that
sounded like me this field doesn't make
any sense and they want figured here
that Gus you think this is just chance
we're all here for a reason
[Music]
love yous
you're a brave girl so what's the story
young lady
we're on our way to Minneapolis it
wasn't an accident
face out well sooner or later everybody
does right dad I nearly had you tonight
since you're travelling I'd like to do a
cat scan daddy's gonna take care of I'm
gonna wait right here for you when you
get up in hours you know how much longer
it's gonna be what was her name again
Harry Monroe
I'm not seeing a Perry Monroe there
hasn't been a scan since an idle talk
this morning what are you telling me
they're not here at the whole day in
front of you not finding any Monroe I
just want to see my wife and daughter
happy face don't record in the treatment
areas right that the camera can't see
them because of the chairs you got a
better angle
you saw my little girl you treated her
own well I've got to go anything word
that they were here at all thinks I'm
making them up
why would I have my daughter scarf but
not her this place should you the
picture that could be anybody
where's concerned about them as you are
nobody needs to get hurt
I mean use a head case
[Music]
should I tell you a story it's the story
of an orphan girl from a faraway land he
was sent to live a mysterious house
[Music]
and what if I were to tell you she
discovered something magical
scooping secret
[Music]
would you believe me
[Music]
[Music]
if you cause me trouble I'll have you
sent away in an instant
[Music]
and you were hiding something this
garden it's capable of extraordinary
things now will you believe in the magic
[Music]
[Music]
yeah finally get you all myself
[Music]
probably one of the kids who are you
talking to last night there was these
college kids he left his cell phone
there I went through it to see whose it
was it's awful
we have meant something I'm scared
you're scared too
you know if you ever need to call them
here so good
yeah acting guilty shame
[Music]
they made me do it
[Applause]
[Music]